my name is Rihanna Hughes and the reset
Rebecca and I went first and I really
really enjoyed it and it was good
actually
a lot busier and a lot more interactive
and I thought it would be I thought it'd
be very similar to what we've done
before of us just watching you talk to
people but the fact that we can actually
interact answer our questions very
inside I love the fact that we was able
to interact and help other people in the
audience not just the people on the
board and actually how different
everybody else on the panel it was
actually quite nice to see was it just
all the same recruitment has a very big
stereotype and you a we've able to get
somebody from completely out of them
stereotypes like this I think if you
learn things here that you might be able
to learn from a video from a message
actually looking somebody in the eye is
so important in what they do but being
able to do that with like-minded people
and actually experts that you're able to
take real things to learn from is
something that you don't get a chance to
do every day
you